meine Damen und Herren die deutsche
Außenministerin Annalena baerbock
befindet sich auf das ist ihr Job auf
einer Auslandsreise sie ist seit gestern
im Irak und wie so viele andere
Fachkollegen auch der deutsche
Verteidigungsminister hat sich heute
schon Interviews geäußert hat sie ein
Statement abgegeben zu den Vorgängen und
vorschnellen Urteilen gewarnt
natürlich verfolgen wir alle Berichte
und auch alle Erkenntnisse die es von
unterschiedlichen Akteuren gibt ganz
ganz intensiv aber die Stärke eines
Rechtsstaates ist es ja dass diejenigen
Behörden die in einem Rechtsstaat in
einer Demokratie für die Aufklärung
zuständig sind dass die ihre Ermittlung
zu Ende führen und wir dann von Seite
der Regierung aufgrund dieser
Erkenntnisse dann auch beurteilen
treffen können und nicht voreilig aus
Berichten heraus Schlüssel für uns
ziehen daher haben wir als
Bundesregierung immer wieder deutlich
gemacht dass der Generalbundesanwalt bei
uns für die Ermittlungen zuständig ist
er ermittelt bekanntermaßen seit Anfang
Oktober 2022 in der Sache er hat damit
auch die Hoheit über das Verfahren und
nicht die Regierung aufgrund unseres
Verständnis von Rechtsstaatlichkeit
darüber hinauslaufen das wissen sie auch
Untersuchung in Schweden und Dänemark zu
den Explosionen jeweils Ort auch unter
der Federführung der dort zuständigen
Behörden und natürlich gibt es
entsprechend auch den Austausch mit
allen ermittelnden Behörden zuletzt vor
wenigen Tagen haben Schweden Dänemark
und Deutschland den Sicherheitsrat der
Vereinten Nationen darüber informiert
dass die Untersuchung noch laufen und
wir noch keine Erkenntnisse geben können
und das ist damit auch die Antwort auf
Ihre Frage